react channels they've taken over
YouTube for quite a while recently
there's been some controversy revolving
streamers and reacting to YouTube
content basically YouTubers who are
uploading original content are getting
them reacted to by streaming and the
reactions vary in quality now I
personally have had some of my videos
reacted to by streamers and I have no
issue with it if anyone wants to react
to my videos they are welcome to it but
I also understand why some YouTubers
don't like that it's a very complex
issue I do want to look at the subject
from all angles and you know I think xqc
has a very interesting video added
insight to the conversation and
hopefully I I can you know critique and
we can analyze some of what's going on
here and hopefully learn more about the
the subject so let's take a look
I gotta grab something I'll be right
back just right back I thought of this
it had like 100k likes okay people being
even done about this again uh people are
forgetting from the nature okay
people want to sit the computer open the
one link okay having a second Monitor
and play games and whatever okay that's
what streams are about streams are [__]
content streams in their entirety are
shipped content only only about to one
percent of the time or about five
percent the content is going to be good
enough okay or it's going to be it's
gonna be main main monitor content
nobody wants to [__] switch channels
80 times like you're on a TV okay so
there that's why that's my talk that's
this is my take okay
when I'm going to react [__] okay yes a
lot of it is just watching it because
that's what chat wants if I commentate
too much chatty gets [__] bored as
Chad gets mad if I got any videos that I
make that are full that are full react I
don't give a [__]
I don't go the money is so little on
that end I don't give a [__]
so yeah that's pretty crazy